[Music]
here we are with Eric Rosen in Saint
Louis chess club Eric I know that you
live very near to this place like how
happened that you're in St Louis and
lives so not so far away yeah and just
leave a few blocks uh away
um I've been living here since uh 2019 I
actually started an apartment with Eric
Hanson uh 2019 through uh basically 2021
and then eventually moved out and uh got
my own place and it's been nice and
having Gatherings and things in ping
pong and um that's super nice to be so
close to the chess club yeah exactly
because it's like now St Louis is a
capital of American chess and maybe even
watches I was wondering how many
Grandmasters visited your house these
days oh I've I've lost counts uh I mean
within the last week it's probably been
five and ten
um definitely some some very strong
players some very strong Book House
action so it's been super fun to have so
many strong players in town
yeah exactly and you were the one who
had this big luck to play against the
world champion Mike muscarlesome before
the tournament has started how is it to
play against the world champion even
though it was in simultaneous exhibition
yeah I was super grateful for it uh
because I was not expecting to get a
chance to play him and now looking back
on it I'm one of the few people that got
to play him this uh this whole event so
uh yeah it was kind of surreal because I
played him online
um a few times before but never like
over the board so it's different
experience I felt a lot of pressure but
uh I really tried to give him a hard
fight and yeah it was a good game and I
I filmed the whole thing I put on
YouTube did some fun analysis so I hope
people uh can find that and watch and
enjoy it and learn a thing or two from
it yeah that's for sure and yes you
mentioned you were one of the luckiest
people that you managed to play against
him and then what what did you feel when
you learned the news that actually
Magnus withdrew from the tournament like
what was your first emotions yeah it was
very shocking like I didn't know what to
think but uh yeah in times like this
when there's a lot of unknown
information like you just have to listen
to everyone and see what's going on and
kind of be patient for more information
to come out yeah exactly I mean lots of
information came out these days but I
don't think you have made any stream on
this topic and like can you explain why
yeah well I was going the day Magnus
withdrew I was going to post our game
analysis recap to YouTube but then he
withdrew and I thought it was bad timing
so I did a very short like 90 second
video just inform people and holding off
on posting the recap here's what
happened uh let's wait to hear more
information
um but yeah it's uh it's one of these
things which is like we're continuing
continually learning more things and I
think it's it's important to be Pat it's
important to be patient and also be kind
of compassionate and empathetic with
everyone involved and uh important to
listen and that's kind of where we're at
right now yeah but many many streamers
are making really hundreds of new
followers you know using the stories the
drama which is happening right now like
don't you feel that maybe it's a good
time you know for to get more and more
views and more and more followers you
know
yeah
um for me I've I try and keep my content
more chess focused and of course it's
it's interesting but I still want to
provide like the more family-friendly
educational content so I've been doing
some streams and some YouTube videos
um but I don't want to make any like
affirmative statements or anything
before kind of we see the big picture so
yeah that's a really nice
of the players I know that you like
photography but actually if you had a
choice like what is your the most
favorite thing to do like to be a
streamer to be a photographer a player
like what do you enjoy the most
I really like the balance I mean taking
photos it's certainly less stressful
than actually playing chess and to just
watch the intensity of an event like
this
um the previous event I photographed
that was a world championship in Dubai
which is also very very interesting
um just to capture
um but I I like the balance I like being
able to to capture the moment but also
do the streams and provide educational
content
um but also compete from time to time
too so it's nice to wear multiple hats
yeah and okay now we are on the seventh
round of single cup like what do you
think about the event itself I mean now
that Madness is not playing like what do
you think about the games and uh any any
comments
yeah I think um I mean it's been a lot
of exciting chess of course there's been
some things distracting from the games
themselves but uh you know a lot of like
hard fought battles and interesting
opening preparation from all players so
as a chess fan it's uh the chess is
certainly not disappointing yeah exactly
thank you so much Eric for your time and
all the best in all your activities
thanks so much
[Music]
thank you